want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you have michael jordan
level talent at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only gabby bernstein
don't wait
go
do it act
now
and really accepting we need you we need
you we need you you are the one percent
you're the percent that says
i'm gonna wake up you are the light
workers you are the ones that have
accepted this call in this lifetime at
this time you have decided to wake up
and chosen to say yes i'm here to be of
greater service than just to feed myself
right i'm here to feed the world i'm
here to give love i'm here to be an
expression of that truth
don't
hold that back
don't play small
we can't we need you
and so really if you are anyone in this
room who has been
sitting on that book idea
waiting a little bit longer before you
start that teacher training
or doing 10 more teacher trainings
before you actually teach
if that's you guys
start and the pressure will be off i
can't begin to tell you i could cry just
saying this the mo the day i taught ego
eradicator i was two weeks into my
teacher training and i said eff it let's
go and i just went and i felt so much
pressure off i felt so much lift
because i just knew i felt this
technology must be shared i can't hold
it i can't keep it for myself i can't
just sit in my apartment by myself like
this
i gotta give this
[Applause]
and sharing it the pressure they just
lifted it was like
thank you thank you thank you and i
wasn't the perfect teacher and i looked
back and i was teaching ego eradicator
wrong everyone's arms were like this
everyone was breathing backwards it was
a mess but i did it and i started
and in those moments when we just get to
go just go
the pressure is off and then we clear
the path and we are guided to the next
right action and that
is the most magnificent thing we could
do right now what's the first step to
overcoming the fear or transforming the
fear
to witness it to be to be the
non-judgmental witness of it
to look at it and say
something's got to give right so so
if you're unwilling to look at your fear
head-on and honor it and and witness i
always say if you don't show up for
what's up it will keep showing up
so looking and saying you know i witness
my resistance and you see that fear as
resistance it's right it's fear is the
resistance to what it is that you desire
and in the absence of resistance you
become a magnet for what you desire you
know when you let go of that fear and
you transcend that fear that's when you
start to become a super attractor that's
when you start to let what is truly
uh of essence for you into your life
what is truly of service for you into
your life what is true happiness into
your life and so looking at the fear
witnessing it calling it by its name and
even if you don't have the tools yet
what happens is when you look at the
fear and you're like oh i see this fear
i see this resistance i see how it's
blocking my life and i choose to see it
differently that's when you're listening
to an audio like this that's when a book
like yours will fall off the shelf a
catalyst
exactly you open up your consciousness
pretty much you crack open your
consciousness to find solutions rather
than find problems
and so when you're not looking at the
fear you're just living in the fear and
you're believing in the problem but when
you witness the fear and you're willing
to see it differently you start living
in a solution as i commit to happiness
fully
exactly what i need is coming towards me
because i become a magnet i become an
energy field that is so magnetizing that
is so excited that so inspired that
other people want to support and work
with that energy and so when we dwell in
the energy of joy and happiness we
become a magnet for that which we desire
so my hope for you all is to start to
think about the things that you want to
succeed in whether it's succeeding in
romantic relationships or succeeding in
your career or succeeding in your health
goals and make a commitment today to
bring more joy
to that area of your life rather than
seeing it as a struggle rather than
pushing forward with all this angst and
negativity and neediness and control
just bring joy to it
your successes will come when you commit
to joy when you commit to happiness so
find more joy in that physical exercise
i've been going a soul cycle i
absolutely love it it's so joyful for me
and that's helping me raise my butt
because that was one of my goals and
success and and then we have these
moments where we want to really bring
joy into our career well if you're
having a hard time in the office just
find ways to have more fun
and as we start to elevate that presence
of joy we will begin to magnetize the
successes in our life and so take this
very seriously bring this practice into
your day-to-day experiences and make joy
and happiness your number one priority
and recognize how your successes will be
brought to you in a form far greater
than you could ever imagine when your
primary focus is happiness i have a very
important lesson that's something i've
been applying in my own life and a
girlfriend of mine called me yesterday
and she said that she was feeling really
attacked and judged by someone at work
and my response was don't defend
yourself don't fight back don't judge
back
your work i said to her is to
the moment that you feel judged and
attacked
do something immediately
to make somebody else feel loved so when
you feel as though someone has attacked
you judged you bullied you doing
anything to make you feel inadequate or
unlovable
do the opposite do the exact opposite go
and do something to make other people
feel good so go make somebody feel
lovable adequate and good enough and
that
simple practice of just
taking yourself out of the knee-jerk
reaction to to fight back or defend but
instead to go give love that can change
everything for you when you feel judged
immediately go give love go do something
kind do something compassionate do
something loving that will be the
quickest way to stop the momentum of the
negative energy there are way too many
haters out there there's so much
negativity there's so much bullying and
there's so much attack and judgment and
that's why i wrote an entire book about
this topic so my hope for you is that
when you feel judged or attacked instead
of attacking back you go give love you
do something to make somebody feel good
you do something that's based on
compassion and love and joy you make
somebody you make someone feel good
about themselves many of us have issues
with productivity
maybe we are overly productive but we're
feeling burnt out all the time or we're
not productive at all because we don't
know where to start
i found personally being in business for
myself for the last 20 years that i have
been a little overly productive i almost
did too much and i was constantly
multitasking and making things happen
and just moving so fast that ultimately
i really burnt out and i started feeling
brain fog i was feeling disoriented i
couldn't focus i was feeling like even
though i for so many years was priding
myself on the fact that i could get so
much done at one time i actually don't
think i was being nearly as productive
as i could have been so i hit a bottom
recently with this productivity overload
and i realized that i had to change my
patterns i had to change my ways i was
then blessed i said a prayer i said i
need some help with my brain fog and i
need some help with my productivity
issue and i that day got an email from
the dr oz show asking me to come on and
do a segment with this lovely author and
dr dr mike dao and me and mike had been
in touch many years
for many years just because he hadn't
been an author we were published by the
same publishers and mike had written a
book about brain fog so that day i'm
like thank you universe you're giving me
exactly what i need i go on dr oz with
mike and i'm backstage with him and i'm
like listen i'm feeling so
chaotic and i'm multitasking so much and
my i feel like i've got brain fog and
i'm forgetting things and he looked to
me says how much are you doing at one
time and i said oh mike i'm doing a
million things at once i have a thousand
tabs up on my screen and he's like these
are big brain no-no's and they're also
productivity no-no's is what he said
because he said that the more i try to
do and the more i try to multi-task the
less i'm actually getting done so he
gave me a tip that i want to share with
you that has changed everything for me
and his suggestion was to just do five
things a day
to make a list of the five most
important things that i need to do that
day and not do number two until i've
completed number one and then once i
complete number one move on to number
two then on to number three and if i
don't get through all five in one day
i'll just pick up the fifth the next day
or wherever i left off i'll pick up the
next day
and to really stick to that list and not
move back and forth and not try to make
a million other things added on to that
list and just be really committed to
that five task list
i did it i started to just be very clear
about the five things i was doing in a
day i told my team i made a a list in my
base camp which is where we keep all of
our notes and i made it really clear to
myself these are the only five things
i'm doing throughout the day
as a result of making it super clear and
conscious to myself that i was only
going to do five things i have been more
productive i have created more have been
more intuitive i have been more inspired
and i've been more creative and cheryl
says what is gabby's biggest fear
good question um
you know i think that i think that
i don't even want to say them out loud
yeah how about that
cool i'd say you find me yeah because i
don't want to bring energy to it yeah
sure i like that can you expand on that
then well here's the deal we all have
fears no matter how committed to love we
are no matter how deeply deeply
connected we are to our own our own
spiritual practice and to god into the
universe we will always have fear you
know unless we somehow become
enlightened which is possible but we
will live with fear and it's it's it's
not that the fear goes away completely
as a spiritual student it's just that
you don't believe in it anymore so when
you ask me to share my fears it's like
talking about something that it's like
not true for me so of course there's
fear and they pop up and they're you
know it's present but it's it's not real
for me so it feels like like i'm doing
the world of disservice to say it out
loud and once you make that willingness
to change the book falls off the shelf
or the teacher shows up in a form that
you could have never imagined
or or you hear something on the radio or
you meet a cab driver or some
enlightened conversation comes into your
realm that all of a sudden is that shift
that you needed to make that change and
create that catalyst that becomes your
greatest accomplishment your greatest
shift
and so that's all we need at first is
that slight willingness
that willingness that i had that desire
to change that moment to shift was all i
needed to become
the woman i am today
to live that life beyond my wildest
dreams
and so when i became ready
i opened up and i said okay i'm ready
for change but what's beautiful and
what's the main purpose of what i teach
is that once you make that decision to
change you do not have to do it by
yourself
you cannot be expected to make these
changes on your own
all you need is that slight willingness
now if you're resenting somebody else
you're really just unconsciously
resenting yourself
so witnessing very quickly
who do i need to forgive is it me is it
somebody else and very quickly turning
it back on to you and choosing the
pathway of forgiveness forgiving
yourself for having a judgmental thought
forgiving yourself for being in attack
forgiving yourself for having a feeling
that is unkind forgiving yourself for
being judgmental towards yourself or
attacking towards yourself whatever is
up for you in the moment just practice
the f word and if you can't get to the
feeling of forgiving yourself
say that you are willing to forgive
yourself just saying in that moment i'm
willing to forgive myself for xyz
i'm willing to forgive myself for being
in this bad mood i'm willing to forgive
myself for what i just said i'm willing
to forgive myself for what i'm holding
on to and just opening yourself up to
the practice of self-forgiveness will
change your mood and your energy in a
minute or less
i i swear by this this is probably the
key to my freedom my happiness my
successes is my willingness to forgive
myself so take that in and and really
own that for you and practice the f word
all the time so the next time you notice
yourself in a bad mood it might just be
right in this moment right now
just say i'm willing to forgive myself
and and see what unfolds see how your
energy changes see how your your
feelings begin to shift and see that bad
mood just dissipate instantly the next
phase here is also to become grateful
for what it is that you do have so if
you're starting to try to create change
in your life you want to make sure that
you're really focusing on what it is
that you do have in your life
so that you feel an energy of gratitude
and an energy of gratitude can really
open you up to this incredible capacity
to feel more energized to feel more
happy
in any given moment where you feel like
oh i don't have what i need or i'm not
supported or things aren't working out
the simple step here is to just say i am
grateful for what i do have
and when we look and we say i'm grateful
for what i do have we create more of
what we want and
the energy of gratitude opens our heart
and it expands our energy and it makes
us a much more wonderful loving person
to be around and with that loving energy
we begin to attract more into our life
and so we want to really make sure that
that energy of gratitude is a very uh
pinnacle part of this this miracle
worker process
which is that we stay committed and open
to what it is that we are here to
receive
and we stay committed and grateful for
what it is that we have
and so you can begin today just by
making a gratitude list and focus on it
and there's so many moments when i think
oh my god i can't believe i have to do
this or i can't put back to get to that
and and then i just think about what i'm
grateful for and it just spins me
immediately out of the crazy chaos and
back into a centered place of love
and so i think that this is a really
valuable tool for you to begin to use
regularly and it's an active tool
throughout the book may cause miracles
when you fully accept that you are here
to be great when you fully accept that
you are here to be happy when you fully
accept that you are here to receive when
you fully accept that you can have
the peace and the serenity and the joy
and the wisdom and the purpose and the
intention that you intend to bring to
the world and that it is all available
to you
that's when life gets very groovy
and so my hope and my intention for
today
is to wake you up to that presence
i more importantly give you a really
great new york city kick in the ass that
says not only i'm awake to it not only
do i believe in it
but i am committed to it
i am unapologetic about my capacity to
be great i'm unapologetic about my
capacity to heal i'm unapologetic about
my capacity to see beyond my physical
sight i'm unapologetic about my capacity
to shine as bright as i can shine
because i trust and i know that when i
shine bright i give others permission to
do the same and in my glow they wake up
too and that
is why we're here
there are no idle thoughts so if you
want to live a mindful life you have to
recognize the magnitude of your thinking
if you're sitting here and you're you
know you're judging your your loved ones
you're judging a friend you're weakening
your own energy and you're weakening
theirs every being around you in some
way is picking up the frequency of your
thoughts some people are looking at me
perplexed like what the hell is she
talking about right now i can hear your
thoughts
again i know exactly what you're
thinking
it's not that i can hear it it's that i
can feel it
think about it you know you could be in
those relationships where like you're
your boss and you know you do everything
perfectly but in your head you're like i
hate you i hate you i hate you i hate
you and they just they don't want to
promote you they don't want to support
you there's constant tension within the
relationship you could say all the right
things but if you don't think it if you
don't transform and clean up your
thinking
then you're literally polluting the
planet so first and foremost we've got
to think about what we're thinking and
so how do we change those thoughts
because you might be thinking okay that
sounds great but like i'm i'm down
negative nancy lane and i don't know how
to change direction
how do i make a u-turn all right so some
simple tools first and foremost witness
it
yesterday i was saying this look look at
your crazy and call it by its name it's
fear
when you see those crazy thoughts show
up in your life when you hear those
thoughts of i'm not good enough i'm
better than that person's terrible i
have two choices
i can continue down the road and i can
continue down that dark path or i can
actually pivot i can redirect i can
choose again
so let's just play it out you're walking
around wanderlust and somebody cuts you
in line to the pizza truck and you know
i'd be pissed
somebody caught me in line on that piece
of truck and
and you want to go like buy that cut me
online
in that space notice your angst
witness your story
and instead of thinking i'm gonna fight
back think that is a call for love
anyone who has the audacity to cut me in
the pizza line
but seriously like anyone that's rude
because i i cut in the pizza line
sometimes like i'm a cutter i
i i like to cut lines
but really what is it it's my own
insecurity being like i got to show
people that i can get ahead of the line
whatever it is right seeing it and being
like that is their call for love that's
their unconsciousness that's their
that's their that's their lack of
mindfulness
really really feel what it would feel
like to be in the action of what it is
that you are dreaming of and what does
that feel like to be
the on the career path that is your
dream or what does it feel like to be
doing the work in the world that you've
been so longing to bring forth or what
does it feel like to be spreading an
empowering message in a unique and
innovative way and in the process of
gathering those feelings we do it
through meditation
sit in your meditation for two to three
minutes a day and just allow yourself to
cultivate the feeling of what it is that
you desire
i have had many experiences throughout
my life where i've just allowed myself
to be in the feeling of service or in
the feeling of excitement of seeing
myself on a stage or in the feeling of
seeing myself sitting next to oprah and
doing an interview and all of those
emotional feelings that came forth in my
meditations became the manifestations of
my life so take very seriously the
thoughts and the feeling when we start
to shift our perceptions
when we start to see things with a
better perspective when we start to see
our experiences as as obstacles turning
into opportunities or a resentment as a
divine assignment to forgive more or a
moment of lack as an opportunity to
focus on what we're grateful for rather
than focus on what we don't have
we start to make these shifts within our
life
what begins to happen is that we begin
to have more faith in that way of being
and so the neat thing that occurs and
this has been my experience the past six
years of practicing the life of a spirit
junkie
is that now
my choices my moment-to-moment choices
are choosing more of a positive
perspective when there's traffic my
first thought is okay i welcome the
traffic to go i start to think about the
ways or if i'm supposed to be late maybe
i'm meant to be there late maybe there's
something greater coming or if something
doesn't happen the exact way that i
believe it should happen i know and my
first thought is there's something way
greater coming so this is just the types
of miracles that occur in the ways that
your mind begins to shift when you start
to practice these principles in your
every corner of your life if you're in
that job where you're feeling like this
isn't working for me i'm not into it i'm
mad about it i get i get upset every
time i walk into the office
the thing that you're missing here
is that and she's looking at me she's
like what's she going to say i need to i
need to know i should give it to me
gabby give it to me
the thing that you're missing is that
when you appreciate what you do have
you create more of what you want
appreciating even the job that isn't the
one that you want forever
actually helps you attract
the next career path
and you think it's counterintuitive
because you're thinking well i don't
want to appreciate this thing i don't
want that's sending out a message to the
universe that i want something i don't
want actually no
the more you appreciate what's in front
of you the more you become a magnet for
what it is that you desire
so if you appreciate that job that's not
that great
and you bring an energy that's a little
bit more of a high vibe frequency and
you show up to work and you've got a
better attitude and people start to like
you a little bit more because you're in
that appreciation of whatever is around
you and they start to see you a little
bit differently and then maybe they give
you a raise or maybe they see some
potential in you or maybe one day you're
just in a really good mood because
you've been appreciating everybody and
you're not you're not mad anymore you're
not complaining on your instagram about
how you hate your job and you're walking
through the office and you're in a
really good mood and you get in the
elevator and you bump into somebody and
they say oh what do you do and you say
i'm a copy editor at this company and
blah blah blah they say oh how
interesting we've been looking for a
copy editor
because your energy
and your
appreciation that creates that
opportunity
so the more that you're an energy of
lack
or fear
or negativity
the more likely you are to deflect the
creative possibilities in your life the
more you are to deflect the new
opportunities
and the less fun you have real you know
what i mean like the key to attracting
what you want people is to have fun
straight up have fun so for our audience
can you define what exactly is
manifesting
manifesting is acquiring the experience
of what it is that you want to feel and
being and living and believing in that
experience and then allowing that
experience to come into form manifesting
is very creative it is the process of
using your power energy and being in
that presence of your high-powered
energy and allowing that energy to
co-create with the energy that's around
you so you're vibrating at a high
frequency i'm vibrating at high
frequency we've done a lot of work we've
cleaned up a lot of our own crap we
believe in ourselves today and that that
energy of believing in ourselves has
attracted us together today and brought
us into this space where we together are
co-creating and teaching if i hadn't
cleaned up my side of the street if i
didn't believe in myself the way i do i
would never have manifested being on
marietv yeah there's a really nice line
from a course in miracles which is the
metaphysical text i teach and it is
miracles occur naturally and when
they're not occurring something has gone
wrong
that's interesting it's a good one right
so what happens is that that
synchronicity that flow that effortless
action that just sort of allowing oh i
was thinking about that and it just
showed up that's how life is supposed to
be
we get in the way our negative belief
systems our fears our anxiety our our
anger towards the past that future
tripping and projecting all of that
energy gets in the way of allowing all
of the miracles to occur naturally the
third step
obstacles are detours in the right
direction so maybe you can begin to look
at your obstacles of maybe that divorce
is an opportunity a detour in the right
direction an opportunity to start to
love yourself some more
maybe that loss of that job is an
opportunity to begin to do that thing
you've been dreaming of
maybe that diagnosis is an opportunity
to get closer to god
take that in
let's reorganize your obstacles right
now what are the opportunities what is
the detour in the right direction in
what way can you begin to turn it upside
down and see it as an opportunity to
thrive and an opportunity to get more
connected to the truth i live up in the
country most of the time and i have a
very good a new friend she just had a
baby she's up in the country living in
the country and she kept her
her
apartment in new york city because she's
like i'm a new yorker i just got to keep
my apartment you know she's cutting
checks every month and she's not not
there
she said my landlord's raising my rent i
don't know what to do and i was like
okay let me ask you a few questions
i said how does it feel
to think about writing those checks
every month
to something that you're not using
and she said oh that does not feel good
i said how does it feel to to think
about getting that baby in the car
driving down to new york city
finding a parking spot on the street of
13th street walking up the four flights
of stairs with the baby and she said oh
that sounds really overwhelming
i said well laura how does it sound to
save that money
get cozy in that house you have up in
the country and then when you want to
come to new york city just get the
fanciest apartment you could possibly
get just get like a thousand dollar a
night apartment because it doesn't
matter because you're saving that and
she was like
that sounds really fun
laura texted me yesterday that she did
not resign the lease so follow the fun
follow the fun follow the fun and this
is the lesson here we're always like you
know where do i want to be what do i
want to get to but we're never asking
ourselves how do i want to feel and the
moment that we start to ask ourselves
how do i want to feel then everything
changes our point of attraction begins
to shift so we've been talking a lot
about ourselves how do we deal with
friends loved ones or going through the
same challenges that we've been
discussing fears anxiety nervous not
living their purpose you know all of
that what about if it's the people
around us that are really struggling
so be the light
right so i think a lot of people want to
change the people around them they want
to say uh you know
you know read this book or watch this
video or do this meditation and that
doesn't work you have to the only
requirement for for membership as a
spiritual student is is the desire is
that is the one is the wanting and so if
somebody doesn't want that then then
you're going to be you know a broken
record so be the light
practice your own transformation get
grounded in your own spiritual healing
and and live it and in the expression of
your light you will reflect that onto
others and they will recognize their own
light in yours so you have a much more
um like a much higher likelihood of
elevating somebody and healing somebody
by just being the presence of that light
being that presence of that
transformation i think that lately i've
been
i've been sort of accepting something
that i've always heard over and over
again which is sort of you know
that that like you know you can speed up
by slowing down which is you know sort
of a old you know age-old spiritual
belief systems like you know the more
you tune in the more happens around you
and i've always preached that and known
that but i'm really like really slowing
down enough now to believe it and see it
yeah yeah amazing because i think it's
so important that everyone
hears inspirational statements we hear
insight we hear wisdom but it takes so
much time for that gravity of that
statement to almost sink into our hearts
and our beings and it's it's okay to
know that it takes time
i love that you say this because it's
it's a practice and it's a path and it's
a commitment and uh and to your point
you you can have this daily path daily
commitment read spiritual books practice
meditation watch people like yourself
and be part of this conversation in your
own unique ways and then there may be
that moment of time where you wake up
and you're like there it is
you know i get that thing that
everyone's been talking about i get that
mantra that i've been preaching and it
drops in we live in a world that
reinforces a scarcity mentality and that
mentality keeps us an energy of lack it
keeps us from attracting the career path
that we want the abundance that we want
and allowing us to really live our
purpose
there are six common blocks to abundance
and we all experience them in different
ways
the first block is a lack mentality and
when we have a belief system around lack
we create more lack in our life
we all have stories from our childhood
how our parents experienced abundance or
how they didn't and those stories start
to create a inner dialogue that gets us
into a vibration of feeling like we
don't have enough
and if we feel like we don't have enough
we do a lot of work to try to prove to
the world that we are enough
the second block is the belief system
that there's not enough to go around
we often overwork to try to get it all
we're constantly trying to get get get
because we don't believe that there is
enough it makes us feel like we have to
work so hard to get what we want and
that effort and that anxiety is really
really blocking the natural order which
is the flow abundance
the third block is the block of
comparison
we
literally just turn on our social media
and we're immediately into compare
compare compare
and comparing blocks are attracting
power because it focuses us on what we
don't have rather than feeling good and
feeling faith
the fourth block is the need to win in
the place of having fun because when
we're so focused on winning we lose
track of what it feels like to enjoy the
process and that winning can really get
in our way of allowing
the fifth block is the fear of rejection
when we fear rejection we don't take
action and in effect we create more lack
in our life because we're not actually
trying we're not actually putting out
our desires we're not actually taking
that leap towards what we want
but it's important to understand that
rejection can be protection
when we have some form of rejection show
up in our life it's the universe guiding
us to something better and the final
block is the fear of judgment
you may be so terrified of being judged
that you don't take that action you
don't show up for your dreams you don't
even contemplate a world where you could
do the thing that you've been dreaming
of you're so afraid of judgment because
you think that other people won't
support you but what's really important
to recognize is that if you're afraid of
what other people think and how they
won't support you it's typically a sign
that you are not supporting yourself now
that you know the six blocks to
abundance i want to give you my methods
for clearing those blocks so that you
can allow abundance to flow to you it's
called the universal abundance method
the first step of the universal
abundance method is to protect your
desires so you can stay in alignment
so if you have a really important desire
something that you care about something
that you want to manifest into your life
it's extremely valuable not to talk
about it with anyone who might resist it
step two is to focus on giving rather
than getting
the more we are in that service
mentality
the more positively the universe
responds to us this puts you into an
abundance mentality quickly because the
more you give the more you will receive
and step three is to want more for
others
it is an opportunity for us to see that
we all can succeed we all can have
abundance in our life and the second you
start to intend for others to have more
of what you want for yourself you start
to feel good you start to feel like
you're contributing you start to feel
like you're connecting and you're no
longer comparing or jealous and you're
no longer separating yourself from
others redirect your focus from what can
i get to how do i feel and really allow
that feeling of abundance to propel you
forward and create momentum and allow
the universe to bring to you all that
you desire one of the biggest blocks to
being a super attractor
is the comparison and the belief that
there's not enough to go around and i
actually wrote a whole chapter in the
book called there's more than enough to
go around
and it's for that person that's like the
pusher that i identified in the book the
person that's like if i don't do it it
won't happen
and everybody around me is better than
me or i'm not or i'm better than
everybody else and that separation and
that judgment that self-attack and all
the ways that we feel unworthy and so
when we start to identify the ways that
we're pushing and controlling we can
begin to unpack that and i guide the
reader in the book to unpack that
behavior and to recognize how much it's
blocking someone from from allowing and
letting what they desire to come into
their life because the real secret
is to feel good the secret is to
love where you are in the moment and not
compare yourself to where you think you
should be because once you start just
being psyched about what is
more of what you desire comes to you and
i can stand behind that wholeheartedly
so i get a call from my one of my team
members and she's like uh don't go on
facebook i was like what she's like
there's a whole
person's facebook page and they're
railing on you and they're going off
about you
and
maybe like 30 people had chimed in being
like oh you hate gaby brizzy thank god
somebody's talking about it just like
you know going after me yeah and
while 30 people is a small number in the
grand scheme of the universe this feels
really overwhelming and and even one
person hating you on the internet can
can shake you to your core so i
lo i just i do what anyone would do in
that moment and i start to go down that
hole of of shame and upset and what did
i do wrong and how could i have
triggered these people in this way and
what you know what is my part and just
getting so hooked into it even though
you know a lot of what was being said
was being said without any information
right uh you know but regardless i
didn't even need to dig into it to feel
the feelings of discomfort and i was
getting really really hung up about it
really hung up about it and took you
know probably it was about a full day of
just like
being down and bummed out and i remember
i was watching television with my
husband at night i was staring at my
phone just being like did more people
weigh in like what's happening and he
looked at me he's like what is going on
what you can't even be present with me
in this room why are you so stuck in
this i was like it feels so horrible to
be
you know pounded on on the internet and
i'm so upset about it and he said listen
you've got it all wrong girl this is
what my husband became my guru he said
you are focusing all your energy on
these 30 people who are hating you but
you have thousands of people on your dm
on instagram that are trying to send you
love that are asking you questions that
want your support and you don't even
know how to find your dm
you and me were in the same boat for a
long time
and he's like you don't even know how to
find it he's like let me show you how to
find your dm and focus on the people
that need you not on these people that
are hating on you so
i spend the next four days just dm'ing
dm i mean dm like i went on my instagram
i was like yo who wants to dm let's
within 48 hours i was just like so
transformed by just being in the service
of others and connecting to the people
that really wanted to to hear from me
and wanted my support and what happened
that was so so transformational was i
woke up one morning a few days into this
and i woke up at like 5 00 a.m and i was
i was upset by
the still a little upset yeah the
thought came right back in oh there they
are why are they talking about me of
course and in that moment i was like
okay zack said get on dm so i get back
on my dm and i start damning and i see
this girl and she's talking to me and
she's saying you know listen i um was
sober for two years i just went out i
feel like i'm i want to commit suicide
right now i started dming with her
within the hour i'm on the phone with
her
and
that day she made a commitment to go
back to recovery
so i have deep gratitude for those
haters because those haters gave me this
beautiful opportunity of service to
somebody and potentially save her life
and and and and also just get over it
when you
before i i mean this must have been five
years ago that we did an interview on
him but before i really
understood why i was so
in control why i was needing to be
because i hadn't remembered my trauma
and i had you know i was living in fight
or flight
i was an extreme pusher uh and in that
energy we may be able to create some
successes but we will never have that
that life that is what we truly want
fulfillment inner peace and we block
bigger stuff too we block bigger stuff
we block it because our energy is just
so frenetic
uh there's also the
the person who's like the manic
manifester who is very a lot of my
audience can identify with this they're
like you know reading all the books you
know reading watching lewis house
watching this you know doing this
meditation every single day
and they're just like why am i not
manifesting why am i not manifesting but
it's because they've made their
spiritual practice another form of
addiction what is the thing that they
need to let go of the most if they are
doing the habits and they are doing the
steps and they are following your work
you just said it they just need to let
go
it's like you can practice these
principles but not because you think
you're going to get something you have
to practice these principles so that you
feel good and this isn't actually a book
on how to get things though it sounds
like it it's a book on how to feel good
yeah because when we feel good we're
super attractive we attract more yeah
super attractive the first step to
feeling good is to decide to stop
feeling bad i've been really working on
getting honest and telling the truth and
being forthcoming about how i'm feeling
i know this is something that can be
very squirrely for people we can get
really hung up about actually saying how
you feel and telling the truth but when
we don't tell the truth we actually
stifle our energy we create toxic
relationships we carry resentments and
it builds up and builds up and builds up
so i've gotten into the practice of just
radically telling the truth wherever i
am however i need to be authentic and
truthful about what i'm feeling but i
have a few steps that i think are
important that you need to take and
you actually give that truth over
because if you share your truth without
cleaning up your side of the street
it'll feel like an attack it'll feel
like judgment so the process of telling
the truth is quite simple
first take a look at your side of the
street look at what's up for you if you
feel called to get honest with somebody
what is it within you that's feeling
triggered what is it that's that's
feeling activated and do whatever you
need to do to clear that whether it be
forgiving yourself forgiving the other
person saying prayers for that other
person sending loving energy to that
other person and clean up the energy
before you bring over the truth because
you don't want to show up with this
nasty attitude because your truth won't
be heard you need to bring your truth
with a lot of light so that they can see
their light reflected back to them
so the process is really simple look at
your side of the street before you show
up and tell the truth and then be
prepared to get honest from a place of
love
if you can tell the truth from a place
of love then you will be heard and
that's when you feel healed and that's
when a healing can be offered up to the
relationship but as long as you're
telling the truth from a place of
negativity or judgment it will not be
heard and it won't work i learned this
the hard way unfortunately but the
experience has given me this great
opportunity to learn how to tell the
truth with grace and power
the benefit of telling the truth is that
you start to feel like you're taking
care of yourself you start to feel like
you're owning your voice you're owning
your needs you're protecting yourself
when you need to protect yourself and
you're sticking up for what your values
are no matter what and you're also just
you know really getting clear about what
your boundaries may be within certain
relationships and so sometimes people
may not like your truth but you could
always trust that if you're sharing your
truth from a place of love you will be
heard even if they get defensive even if
they get upset that your loving presence
is enough
to allow that truth to come through in a
very authentic way
the other part that may be very helpful
is once you've told your truth give the
person their opportunity to tell their
own hold that space for them to say how
they feel there's always two sides to
every story so speak up and then allow
the other person to speak up clearing
that space for the truth to unfold and
trusting that the truth will totally set
you free my mom has always said this to
me for my entire life the truth will set
you free the truth will set you free
and i believe that we all want freedom
we want freedom from resentment freedom
from anxiety freedom from fear and that
freedom is available as we start to open
up to the truth within us i write in the
book about how
i'm going to push the metaphysical
envelope and i'm going to go to places i
haven't gone before and i never went
there before because i didn't want to
alienate my reader and i had a lot of
new seekers that were joining me on this
journey but i feel right now that people
are completely ready for this
conversation and they can take it or
leave it yeah and make it their own yeah
and my beliefs do not have to be theirs
that's a really important point that
whatever we believe when we think about
a higher power spiritual presence is
what we believe and all that matters is
that you believe it not that someone
said it's this or that it's it's it may
be a religious spiritual belief system
it may be a belief system from your
childhood maybe something that you read
in a book that resonated with you you
decide that's the beautiful thing about
being on a spiritual path but what i
share is what i believe to be true about
what it means to connect to the voice of
our higher self our inner guidance
system and our inner wisdom versus what
it means to rely on a guide or a angel
or a deceased family member uh or a
loved one and so i believe we all have
these two this t we all have a team of
of guides of spiritual guides that work
on our behalf all the time and what
they're there for is often to guide be a
bridge for our thoughts so when our
thoughts are in those low vibrations if
we pray to a guide or we pray to god or
we pray to an angel we can say thank you
for for bridging my thought from this
low vibrational fear-based belief system
to a higher vibe and the way that they
would do that may be by putting a book
in front of you or guiding you to an
episode of marietv that is going to just
change your mind so guides work through
the internet and books and people and
and and your and your subconscious and
so you're gonna maybe when you have
those moments where you're like i have
this sense that i need to to watch that
episode of marietv right now maybe
somebody watching just got the hit yeah
that could have been your guide just
giving you that boost of inspiration
watch that watch that because that's
gonna change you and so don't
underestimate those moments of
synchronicity because there's support
that's leading you in those
synchronistic moments and so the more
that we align with our spiritual belief
systems and the more we
allow ourselves to accept that it's good
to feel good and the more we use things
like the emotional guidance scale or the
choose again method or any of the
methods in this book the better we feel
and the better we feel the more we can
hear the guidance that we're receiving
the guidance is always there but we
block it we cut it off and so we can
open up to that guidance
when you notice that you're in that
story and that trauma of your you know
negativity fear or judgment attack
that's making you feel bad notice it
notice the thought right away
and then you say how is this thought
making me feel
that's step one notice the thought and
how is it making me feel and the second
step is to forgive yourself for having
the thought not beating yourself up why
i used to do this all my life why am i
having such an idiot why am i so stupid
why can't i figure this out what is
wrong with you that was my pattern for
years i know i know
so how do we get out of that forgive
yourself for having the thought forgive
the thought if you can't forgive
yourself for having thought cause that
just feels too heavy for you just
forgive the thought like okay that's
that's that thought again
that's from my childhood trauma that's
from mike's you know my fear of this
that's from whatever there it is again
and then the third step is to start to
proactively choose again and this is
where we begin to reach for the next
best feeling thought we've reached for
this is a um very influenced by abraham
hicks which is written you know
mentioned 23 times in that book what was
it called like the purge of appreciation
or something
rampage of appreciation yeah so one you
want to choose again in that third step
you're going to reach for a thought that
you believe in so what if you don't
believe in any good thoughts you you
have you have a thought that could be
better and here's here's what it could
be it could be
i
can turn on lewis howes's podcast right
now and that might make me feel better
that that's a that's a thought right
right or i have that book that i could
open a page too and maybe it'll give me
inspiration or you know just something
as simple as like i'm gonna go for a
walk for five minutes that might make me
feel bad right so and then you keep
going you keep reaching for it so you
reach for
the thought uh i'm gonna go for a walk
i'm gonna let myself feel better then
you go you know you go for that walk and
uh i'm gonna just listen to some music
that music might make me feel better or
the next thought could be i actually
have dinner tonight with my friends so
that will be great and i can bring
myself to that uh but little things like
my credit card got stolen and i'm on the
phone with the credit card company i'm
trying to get out of the hotel with my
son and
i have a nanny with me so like my
nanny's like oh the baby pooped you know
i'm on the phone with the credit card
company there's no uber in santa fe and
the baby's pooped and you're just like
you know these moments and so i start
going into the i'm out of control
so i notice it really quickly now i
witnessed the thought i forgive myself
for acting out and being rude to the
woman at the credit card company and
then i choose again okay let's change
the poopy diaper let's get in the car
have fun at this moment yes i could have
carried that negative thing all the way
down to santa fe having lunch but i
decided to turn it around quickly yeah
and that's how we can we can start to
live like that there's no such thing as
a mistake everything happens in divine
order i am being guided to learn and
grow here we go people
when we look at the situations in our
life from a place of regret
we ultimately miss the opportunity for
growth we miss the opportunity to see
what could have been
beneath that discomfort we miss the
opportunity to acknowledge and recognize
that every experience in our life is not
an accident it doesn't happen by
accident it happens in a divine order
and when we live and lead and show up
for our life
grounded in that belief system
then we can face our most
difficult moments
with a
sense of purpose and power
and we can show up for those moments
with a opportunity to grow focusing on
the opportunity to grow focusing on the
opportunity for a shift for strength for
spiritual awakening for a new way of
being and a new perception of our lives
so that's a lot i know that's a lot i
know that when something really bad
happens like what we've been
experiencing recently in the world what
we experienced in the united states last
week when we experienced something like
a pandemic we don't want to see the
spiritual assignment we don't want to
see that this is not a mistake
but typically when difficult things
happen they are revealing what needs to
be healed these uncomfortable moments
whether they be global or they be
personal are revealing what we have to
heal whether we have to heal it on an
individual level which is where it
begins and what we have to heal on a
global perspective on a global level so
showing up to all these uncomfortable
moments and recognizing them that they
are not a mistake that they are
happening in a divine order and it's our
opportunity to perceive these situations
from the lens of what can i learn from
this how can i grow from this how can i
shift from this how can i lean towards
more love how can i lean towards more
joy how can i lean into the lesson
rather than the problem the solution
rather than seeking all of the faults
and and looking for all of the problems
i think it's really valuable for us to
recognize that
we
when we're on a spiritual path that's
our path but it's not for everybody and
not everyone wants to
know every detail of our path
um we have to trust that our shift in
perception our energetic changes are the
raising of our own energy will help
raise the energy of other people around
us and hopefully we'll start to see how
we are no longer an energetic match for
the people that don't think and feel the
way that we feel and so slowly we'll
begin to see those folks begin to melt
away we'll see them disappear we'll see
them fall off in our life and we'll see
some of our relationships begin to
change
and sometimes that's a little bit
alarming for people but it's actually a
good sign
it's a sign that
you are not
stuck in that pattern anymore it's a
sign that your desire to change has been
lifted and that you now are vibrating at
a new frequency and those relationships
will melt away
if those relationships are still coming
up for you while you're in this path of
transformation
what i often say is rather than pointing
the finger at those people saying oh
you're ruining my life you're making
things difficult
my hope and my intention for you would
be that you begin to look at those folks
and say what is it about me that is
still triggered by their behavior what
is it in me that may be attracting this
type of person into my life what is it
within me that is still calling in this
kind of experience and so get honest
with yourself what is it within me
that's calling this in how am i
participating in this and how is this
experience uh coming from a dark corner
within my psyche and recognizing that
the outside world is always reflecting
our internal condition
and recognizing the mirror that people
are always mirroring back to us what we
are feeling so if she has people coming
up into her life negative friends people
that are jealous she says negative
people randomly popping back in
and she wants to keep them in a distance
well the real work is to just open and
rev up your practice
pray for them
extend light to them and sometimes
politely excuse yourself from the
experience sometimes we have to remove
ourselves from those experiences and
then most importantly ask yourself what
is it within me that may be attracting
some of this behavior get honest with
yourself no matter what's up
choose to show up
with love
choose to show up with grace now if
something really tough is up maybe just
choose to show up with self-compassion
if you're going through something i'm
not going to sit here and recommend if
you're going through a traumatic period
in your life i'm not going to recommend
that you wake up and you're like it's
rainbows and butterflies and gabby
bernstein's spirit junkie app no that's
not what i'm going to match that's not
what i'm going to recommend what i'm
going to recommend is you wake up and
you say
i'm going to choose to see myself with
love today
i'm going to choose to be compassionate
and kind to myself today i'm going to
choose to go slow today
but that's still a very very mindful
morning
okay so more in the morning is probably
the most crucial time to be conscious of
your mindfulness and show up with grace
and show up with love and bring it bring
it bring it bring it in the morning so
i'm in this three year journey of trying
to conceive and
really for
year and a half almost two years i was
like in the low of it really feeling
like okay i'm not good enough my body
isn't working how can i make this happen
how can i make this happen right and
really pushing and controlling and
trying to eat things and
track my ovulation and all that crap
and then about the fall of 2017 i
started to get into more of a
surrendered state and i started
practicing the methods that i teach in
the book of just really
trusting that there
was
a
higher guidance that i believed in for
my whole life and relying on that and
that's when things started to get really
wild and synchronistic and so around the
fall of 2017 i was driving in the
countryside where i lived most of the
time and this is where i do the majority
of my manifesting is just driving in the
car looking at the foliage listening to
my mantra music and i feel so awesome
when i'm in that position and i'm just
so grateful in the moment and i'm
driving and i'm driving i'm like i feel
so awesome and so grateful that i live
in this country town i have all these
friends and i don't have any cell
service right now and i'm so psyched
about that and no one's bothering me and
i feel good and then all of a sudden i
felt the presence of a baby in the back
seat
and i was like
wow like deeply moved tears started to
roll down my face i felt so moved
and at that point i heard my intuition
say to me
the baby's coming in march
and i was like and it was so loud like
you know when you hear the voice of your
inspiration you're like that's it okay i
believe and so i started saying to
myself over and over like oh my god
march you know i have to conceive at
this time for the baby to come and watch
i saw myself getting a little into it
like too into it and hooked into it so i
said okay listen you know what universe
i'm gonna give this over and if my baby
is indeed coming in march show me a sign
show me lily's to let me know that the
baby's coming in march
and a week later i got a letter in the
mail from a reader and it had this angel
card in it and on the back of it was
this picture of archangel gabriel and
archangel gabriel is typically depicted
holding lilies so i was like yo this is
dope and on the back he wrote
i thought that you needed this i was
like thank you good so here i am march
march is coming march is happening and
early march rolled around and i wasn't
pregnant so i was like what the hell and
not only was i devastated once again
another month has gone by i'm not
pregnant but this time i was like i
thought the universe had my back like i
was getting signs like what what's the
uh what's up
so i walked into my husband's office and
i was just hysterically crying so upset
so defeated
and at some my phone was like on the
desk like right here
and all of a sudden my phone started
playing a song
and the song was just repeating
repeating so i go like you know when
your phone malfunctions you're like i'm
just gonna turn that off i was like okay
i'm gonna turn out and then i look at
the phone and i start listening to the
lyrics and the lyrics are
way go lily
way go lily and the guy keeps repeating
way go lily and then i look even further
and i look at the name of the song as we
go lily and he keeps repeating lily and
i look even further and the album title
is i see the sign
and where was this playing where what
area of your phone this was just my
phone just turned on oh no that's you
know it's spirit working through the
technology and so my phone just turned
on it was an album that i'd never heard
i'd never heard the song before it
wasn't in my spotify and it just began
playing now get this
so i get i april rolls around and i'm
pregnant
but then i did the math and i was like
when did i conceive
i conceived the last day of march
so that
synchronicity you know you hear march
you find your signs you feel super
guided that synchronicity is available
to all of us but it's when it had we
have to get out of that pusher mentality
and out of that controlling behavior to
allow the presence of spirit to work
through us and guide us and or the
universe or whatever use whatever you
call it to be the presence of of of
direction inspiration
to be that guide there's always a
spiritual assignment there's always
something to learn there's always an
opportunity for growth in all
relationships particularly romantic
relationships
but when that learning
is no longer
happening when
one person's growing and the other
person isn't
when there is a
leap spiritually and the other person is
not leaping with
there can be a
disconnect in the learning opportunity
the
idea that we could be
forcing a relationship if you have a
sense that you're forcing a relationship
it's likely that you are it doesn't mean
that the relationship isn't right it
means that you are trying to make it
right rather than allowing it to show
you what's right rather than
trying to make someone who you think
they should be
allow them to teach you
who you really are here to step into not
teach you but reflect back to you who
you are here to step into
rather than
trying to change someone else put the
mirror back on yourself and say what is
it within me that is ready to develop
more what is it within me that is ready
to grow more if you show up like that
and you keep growing and you keep rising
up and they don't rise with you there's
your answer
if you keep focusing your side of the
street keeping your side of the street
clean what is it that i got to work
through here how can i show up more and
they say oh okay i'm gonna be a
reflection of her new shift and i'm
going to grow as a result of her growth
and i'm going to be new because of this
development within her then you are both
energetically growing together if you're
here and he's not growing with
there's your answer there's your answer
you know if you're trying to force him
to get here with you you are forcing the
relationship put the focus right back on
top to you
change your inner work your inner life
reflecting that mirror back onto
yourself
and if he starts to vibrate at a higher
frequency as you do you know the answer
it's very easy to show up at work every
day and say i hate this i can't stand my
boss i hate sitting next to this person
my cubicle sucks there's a million ways
we can get completely whacked out with
the stories of why we don't like our job
so just have fun and and and lean
towards the things that that elevate you
and the more you focus on the things
that are fun for you and the more you
focus on the on the good that is around
you the more fun you become the more
cool you become when you're in that
place of your cool people want to do
more with you you'll get those
assignments that are going to be far
more exciting the people that may be
difficult in your career relationships
will start to actually
change they'll see you differently
they'll act differently around you when
you're having a good time the people
around you have a good time and that
will help you get ahead very quickly
smoothly and with joy if you want some
incredible motivation from louise hey
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe i'll see you there i know that
you've heard me say many times or you've
read or
listened on the tapes that loving
yourself
is the most powerful thing we can do
then everything flows
everything flows